bush le président ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'intérieur
paris déjà meurtri par des attentats
d'une ampleur inégalée a subi une
nouvelle attaque terroriste visant l'un
de ses principaux sites touristiques
seul le sang-froid et la réactivité de
la patrouille sauvagement agressé au
louvre ont permis d'éviter le pire
je voudrais d'abord exprimer ici à nos
soldats notre reconnaissance et notre
soutien comme à toutes les forces de
sécurité engagées depuis de si longs
mois au dedans et en dehors de nos
frontières dans une guerre contre la
barbarie
cette agression nous rappellent que la
menace est persistant mais aussi que les
forces de l'ordre en sont l'une des
cibles privilégiées
notre devoir est donc de les en prémunir
dans l'accomplissement de leur
périlleuse mission
le malaise des policiers en colère dans
les rues provient aussi d'un cadre
d'usagé des armes inadaptées
pourtant avec mes collègues eric ciotti
et qu'il arrive et ce n'est pas moins de
quatre propositions de loi que nous
avons déposé toutes rejetées
il aura fallu attendre ce jour pour
examiner un projet de loi qui le
reconnaître enfin un droit renforcé à l'
usage des armes mais l'assassinât de
clarissa jean-philippe l'a prouvé les
terroristes ne faut pas la différence
tous les effectifs en uniforme sur la
voie publique sont menacés et les
policiers municipaux de nice ont dû
aussi affronter le tueur au camion fou
porter un uniforme c'est d'être une
cible avez vous déclaré monsieur le
ministre c'est pourquoi vous ne pouvez
écarter d'un revers de main nos
amendements qui est temps de ce nouveau
droit aux policiers municipaux et aux
agents de sécurité armés des services
publics de transport les habilitant
notamment interrompre un périple
meurtrier eux aussi protège la vie des
français ne les empêchait pas de sauver
la leur la parole est à monsieur bruno
le roux ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
le député philippe goujon vous me
permettrez d'abord avec vous de
souligner la très grande responsabilité
le professionnalisme dont ont fait
preuve les militaires de l'opération
sentinelle et la grande réactivité des
fonctionnaires de la préfecture de
police de paris qui moins de 17 minutes
après cette attaque avait mis à l'abri
plus de 1200 personnes touristes
visiteurs qui étaient là pour éviter ce
qui peut vous le savez dans ce genre de
cas être une grande possibilité lesur
attentats la nouvelle attaque est donc
c'est dans une coordination parfaite que
l on a mis à l'abri et fait en sorte
d'arrêter ce terroriste qui a prêté à
commettre bien entendu un attentat vous
m'interrogez sur le cadre d'un usage des
armes à feu dont sony ou de discuter
dans quelques minutes d'abord je veux
vous rassurer je ne balayent aucun
amendement
d'un revers de main je pense que ce
débat doit avoir lieu
vous me permettrait simplement de vous
renvoyer une interrogation alors que
nous sommes en fin de session
est il utile que votre groupe déposent
une motion de renvoi en commission qui
ferait que ce texte pourrait ne pas être
adoptée du tout si jamais elle était
adoptée je vous renvoie à une forme de
cohérence qui doit faire en sorte que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités dans
l'hémicycle
je ne pense pas qu'il soit aujourd'hui
compte tenu de ce qu a besoin notre pays
responsables de faire une motion de
renvoi en commission sur ce texte je
vous le dis de la façon la plus claire
qui soit pour le reste les règles de la
police nationale et des polices
municipales ne sont pas les mêmes
il y à une homogénéité d'un côté une
hétérogénéité dans l'autre nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre mais pour l'
usage des armes en légitime défense
les propositions vous faites ne pose pas
de difficulté pour ce qui relève par
exemple du périple meurtrier notion que
nous avons déjà abordé lors des
précédents textes cela en pause
j'exposerai dans le débat pourquoi
j'espère que nous pourrons avoir un
débat serein
merci la parole est à monsieur michel